afc north quarterback in the news today
not because he saw
a ufo but because
well i'm not going to go there the
bottom line is the steelers in big ben
have their contract done and you know
peter
i don't know about you but i had a
feeling this
odd delay in something that could have
been done in a half hour
if all they're doing is taking his 19
million dollars
and moving it around and creating cap
space
by converting the maximum amount 18.975
million nine two five million excuse me
into a signing bonus would have been
easy
nothing and it made me think they're
trying to take some of his money
and they did take some of his money they
took five million dollars from ben
roethlisberger 19 down to 14.
they took the remaining 14 did the
restructuring trick
maximum signing bonus or 12.925 million
1.075 million in salary
they uh they've created 14 million in
cap space
but they know that 19 million in cab
space that not 19.
wait i'm i'll i'll get it right
eventually if i say enough teens i'll
get there
15 million in cap space no 14 million in
cap space
14 million whatever it is they reduce
the cap space we'll work on the cap
space
14 million is what he's going to make
instead of 19 million that's 5 million
off the top that's an easy math problem
for me
and and i was surprised by it i was
surprised that it happened even though
ben had said
he doesn't care how much he gets paid
this year you can say that
all you'll want doing it is a different
proposition altogether
yeah this this reminds me a lot mike
you remember back in 2015 i mean peyton
manning
at the time peyton manning was playing a
lot
better that well he was playing better
than ben roethlisberger
uh played at the end of last year let's
just say that he wasn't playing a lot
better
than ben overall but he ended the 2014
season on a great roll uh
you know 2012 13 and 14 in denver
and john elway came to him in the spring
you know before the league year began
and he basically said hey peyton
i know you're great you've been great
for us we got to take your 20 million
down to
and are down to 16 excuse me and
we will put the rest of the money that
we're taking away from you
with this little salary haircut we're
going to put the rest of it
in uh bonus money incentive bonuses
and you know not just performance but
what the team does
it turns out they win the super bowl and
so he gets all of his 20 million that
year
you know the the 4 million was used
if you remember mike to sign a guard
that they felt they desperately needed
evan mathis now it turns out mathis
didn't really work out for them that
year
but this reminds me very much of that i
don't know that
the the five million dollars that the
steelers will save
uh in this is going to go to one player
or if it's just gonna go to the pool
i assume it's just gonna go to this pool
that they need to try now
hey look mike whether this means
that they can get one of their free
agents back
i doubt they're going to do that with
bud dupree doubt it
and i doubt they're going to do with
james connor either but
if they use it for one guy you know
that will be a good use of the money but
i think
they're probably just putting it toward
the larger pool of money
that they need right now to sign all
their
you know all their guys who are who are
on the cusp
i think you're absolutely right and i
finally got in my teens
together it's 19 million he was supposed
to make down to 14 million he
will make with 15 million in cap space
created
he still has a significant
cap charge 26.25 million
under his name for this year better than
41 of that
far better than 41.25 which is what it
was supposed to be
and peter i'm glad you mentioned peyton
manning because
they took the multiple millions away
from him
in his last year with the denver broncos
he wasn't happy about it
he ultimately earned it all back by
winning the super bowl
i was a little surprised that they
didn't give ben
a similar path to earn the the money
back that that he's not going to make
this year he gives up
5 million why not let him you know even
if it's just
2 or 3 million put an incentive on there
that if you win the super bowl you get
this back that's a hell of a problem to
have
if they end up next year having to
account for
that extra money that's how it would
work it wouldn't rector actively apply
to this year's cap it applies to next
year's cap and
look if he's done playing next year
there's going to be a reckoning there's
going to be
a cap charge all the money that got
pushed forward from this year that 15
million is going to hit next year but
throw on a couple more million
if you end up winning the super bowl
that falls into the good problem to have
category and i'm surprised they didn't
do it and
maybe ben wanted it and they just said
no we're not doing it
i mean that's possible mike but i think
and i'm not saying ben roethlisberger's
words
hung himself but you know he basically
came out and said look i don't care
about the money i made
and he's a different cat he just
is i i i'm not really that surprised
that he's doing this
because i think he feels like hey look
you know
if i keep making the money that i'm
supposed
to make all of my teammates i'm gonna
walk in the room
uh you know when we get to latrobe or if
there is even a latrobe this summer
or just their their their locker room
that you know in august i'm going to
walk into the room and i'm going to look
at guys
because i can tell you mike this is the
way some veterans feel sometimes
that they walk in the room and guys are
looking at them sideways
because they're the eight the
quarterbacks are the 800 pound gorillas
and all the rest of the guys in the
locker room end up
to some degree many of them end up
making less
because of what the quarterback makes
and that's the way life goes we all
understand it it's not it's it's
nobody's fault it's just the way it goes
but
i think in this particular case ben
roethlisberger
throws a lifeline to some guys in his
own locker room
who are going to look at him and say hey
listen he's the quarterback
but he got a five million dollar haircut
and so i think to some degree mike
this is one of those things that
roethlisberger probably curried a little
bit of favor in the locker room with
there's also a pragmatic element to this
peter one of the points we had made
before this became final 19 million
dollars that ben was due to make no one
else would have paid him 19 million
dollars if he was available as a free
agent this year i'm not sure that
someone else would have paid him
14 million dollars not the steelers were
going
to cut him or that more importantly ben
was going to go play for someone else
but your market value has to factor into
this
to some degree the other side of it too
what would they have done without him
they would have been throwing in the
terrible towel on the season before it
even began
because your options are mason rudolph
josh dobbs and dwayne haskins so they
needed each other
even though this this expectation that
they're keeping the band or
whoever they can manage to keep from the
band other than big ben
together for a year is somehow going to
be a championship
contender i think they're deluding
themselves if they think this is like
2005 when jerome bettis came back for
one more year
mike i would disagree with you on the
fact that nobody would have paid him 19
million
i disagree fervently it because
you know what we learned with jj watt
when we said well
nobody's guaranteeing that guy's 17 and
a half million
well he got guaranteed 23 million even
though it's not
only over one year it's over a couple of
years
but i would be surprised quite honestly
if ben roethlisberger were on the street
and either the losers in the deshaun
watson derby or if russell wilson got
traded
the losers in that derby who also didn't
get a quarterback in the draft who they
think can play right away
like what do you think matt rule and
scott federer
and david tepper in carolina would have
thought of ben roethlisberger on the
street
just my gut feeling somebody in the nfl
would have paid ben roethlisberger 19
million this year
or or or when he would have signed
somebody would have reported it's 19
million then when we finally get the
contract the truth is it would have been
a lot less than that but nobody cares
about the real numbers
that come out two days later they only
care about the fake numbers
that multiple reporters will gladly
disseminate as lies to their audience
because that's how the sausage gets made
because if you don't participate
in lying to the audience you don't get
the scoops case in point all we know
about
j.j watt he's going to make 14.5 million
this year the rest of it
who knows injury guarantee i'll submit
for the
remainder up to 23 but if he comes
through the season healthy and that just
say we don't want to do this next year
he walks away with one year 14.5 million
3 million less than what he was due to
make from the texans and
uh market value for him 14 and a half so
i just
i i don't think he wanted to go there i
don't think he wanted to finish his
career somewhere else and we're gonna
have a draft coming up later in the
program of guys
who hung around one year too long a lot
of the guys who hung
around one year too long went to another
team for that one last year and it was
not
good so i i don't think he would have
played for someone else
but um they had they had to do it they
had to drop it down now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports